bonjour jean de gliniasty merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on le disait tournée européenne de
sérier lavrov après les visites en
autriche et en hongrie quel bilan
pourrait faire de cette tournée
européenne
elle avait plusieurs buts d'abord
sergueï lavrov a rencontré les hongrois
les autrichiens qui sont deux nations
qui jouent un rôle plutôt modérateur
dans les relations entre la russie et
l'union européenne
et puis l'italie l'italie parce que
vitaly d'abord et préside le g20 et que
mario draghi a proposé une concertation
particulière sur la crise afghane et sur
la crise afghane il est clair que la
russie et les pays du g7 et les pays du
g20 et l'union européenne ont des
intérêts communs qui concerne à la fois
la question du terrorisme et la question
des migrations à vous l'avez dit hein
donc aujourd'hui sergueï lavrov et en
est en italie on vous parliez à
l'instant de de l'afghanistan à quelles
pourraient être les points communs
justement de la russie et d'italie
autour de la question de l'afghanistan
alors l'italie va proposer une
concertation sur les questions
migratoires puisque l'italie et d'un
front important si je puis dire sur les
questions de migration
l'itavi comme je l'avais dit préside le
g20 et donc c est là deux promus en
quelque sorte une concertation
particulière avec les pays qui ne sont
pas membres du g7 les pays du g20 mais
dans un contexte spécifique dans afghan
donc donc en fait italie va chercher à
promouvoir une réunion particulière avec
la chine avec la russie avec l'inde avec
les pays du g7 et les pays de l'union
européenne en tout cas certains d'entre
eux pour adopter autant que possible une
ligne commune des lignes directrices
commune sur les questions migratoires et
les questions du terrorisme
on parlait d'autres sujets qui pouvaient
intéresser les deux pays comme la
situation en libye où là où la situation
l'ukraine vous pensez que ces deux
sujets vont faire partie des discussions
entre entre les deux pays
je vois que l'ukraine d'abord est un
point de passage obligé de tout
entretien entre les ministres de l'union
européenne et les ministres et bruce et
donc après la séquence récente la plate
forme de crime et la visite de monsieur
et l'ins qui
aux états unis qui se prépare doit avoir
lieu dans les jours qui viennent
donc la question de l'ukraine et bien
entendu au premier plan de l'ordre du
jour sur la libye l'italie l'italie un
rôle très particulier puisque la libye a
été pendant longtemps un peu en
concurrence avec la france
dans l'histoire libyenne
la libye estime qu'elle a un rôle
particulier à jouer et on sait que la
russie aussi à essayer de promouvoir un
accord qui est actuellement en cours il
faut préparer des élections on sent que
c'est difficile les élections risquent
d'être reportés et donc le règlement de
la crise libyenne est prioritaire pour
l'italie est importante pour la russie
qui joue un rôle
un grand rôle on le disait donc la
visite de sarov s'achève un en italie
pas de visite en france en tout cas
prévu est ce que vous pensez qu russes
et français auraient pu se rencontrer
lors de cette tournée européenne
il ya moins d'une semaine je crois que
le président français ait eu un
entretien d'une heure et demie avec le
président poutine et je crois que ces
questions ont été abordées au téléphone
merci beaucoup aux gens de l'inasti
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france rappelle que vous êtes ancien
ambassadeur de france en russie et
auteurs de petites histoires des
relations franco-russes merci beaucoup